it's a remarkable personal story but
what was behind the deal that bought
nazanin home and what could it mean for
future relations with iran so this is
the number that matters today just shy
of 400 million pounds the amount
transferred from the uk to iran
restricted for humanitarian purposes but
why well it comes down to historic debt
over this 1
750 tanks iran ordered and paid for them
all the way back in the 70s but the uk
never completed the order now it's a
hugely significant breakthrough but is
it going to herald a broader thawing of
relations well the key to that probably
lies here talks in vienna to try and
salvage the iran nuclear deal remember
it fell apart in 2018 when the u.s
withdrew under donald trump it hinges on
iran agreeing to reduce its capacity to
develop nuclear weapons in exchange for
the removal of harsh economic sanctions
this is why it matters so much to the
west this is stockpiles of enriched
uranium in iran the stuff needed to
develop that weapon just look at how it
fell right off after that deal was
struck but after the u.s left it started
to rack up again given the current
threat from russia this now matters more
than ever but there would also be huge
benefits to iran just look at what
happened to its economy after that deal
was struck in 2015 gdp that red line
started growing inflation came down but
after the u.s left the very opposite
happened the economy started to contract
an inflation look all the way up there
surging nearly 40 percent sanctions also
prevented iran from selling it's oil
freely again look after the deal was
struck production and exports both up
and after the u.s withdrew and those
sanctions started to bite it's really
fallen off now this matters for both
iran and the west oil is one of the
bedrocks of the iranian economy and it
won't have escaped anyone's attention
that the uk and others will now be
looking for new places to buy after
recently committing to not buying oil
from russia so could iran plug part of
that gap well in supply terms it's
certainly possible look at this iran has
the third largest proved reserves of oil
in the world after saudi arabia and
venezuela the only two countries ahead
and we know that the prime minister is
already courting other sellers this is
him today in fact he's traveled to the
uae and saudi arabia to help shore up
some of that global supply there would
of course be other obstacles to
repairing relations with iran not least
human rights and regional politics but
nazanin returning home is a huge
breakthrough a further thawing could
benefit both sides